the day at the time you do not comply
with a an instruction in a company like
UBS where everything is so organized you
are the black sheep you are the person
to eliminate for years Stephanie Gebo
led a normal life in Paris as a
marketing specialist for the French
subsidiary of UBS a major Swiss bank her
job was to organize golf and theater
events for clients you do with wealth
with wealthy clients with people who can
buy everything who can afford everything
and this was a very difficult part of my
job it was to invite them to events that
they couldn't buy with money but the
point of these exclusive events was not
to have fun it was to do business she
bows Swiss colleagues also attended
customer consultants from UBS
headquarters she kept detailed lists
with information about the rich guests
and then suddenly she was told to make
names disappear what my boss wanted me
to delete was the content of excel files
which I was preparing and saving for
each event so I had something like 100
events a year or so between 600 and 1000
five where had the name of the clients
being invited linked to their client
advisor at the time back in two thousand
eight UBS was making front pages around
the world things in Paris's Bank
district were still quiet when Stephanie
Gebo learned that her employer had been
helping wealthy clients in the United
States evade taxes then it dawned on her
there were parallels in France if i had
heard when joining the bank that working
with those people who were selling
offshore products to french citizens on
the french territory was illegal i would
never have done it i would never have
accepted to to work for them
so it's it's a big line so i had to
digest that gebo refused to cover up the
deals the bank's response was swift and
hostile she was mobbed then shunted
aside days which were so busy and so
interesting that it turned out to be
boring and I experience loneliness and
solitude a situation where you just get
mad and when I left the bank I was
terrible but I was I was not alive
anymore it took me we are almost two
years or and still now I'm still I'm not
one hundred percent you know because
it's so much energy proving all the time
that what you tell is right that what
you did was the right thing G Fool has
been out of work for over three years
now her life has changed completely she
now meets regularly with other
whistleblowers and tries to help tax
authorities in their worldwide struggle
against illegal bank transactions a
woman who stands up to the financial
industry she's already won two cases
that made it to court now UBS is suing
her again the course of the current
debate in the French parliament in Paris
offers little hope of better legal
protection in the future for
whistleblowers in France
whistleblower is not a profession
because you lose everything as a
whistleblower so it's a profession where
you you you know who is your life so not
i will continue defending all the ones
who stand up for the truth all the ones
who defend the rights of the citizens
because what we do is not for us it's
for the others at 50 gebo has now given
up hope that she'll find a new job she's
concentrating instead on bearing witness
in the big trial against UBS France has
charged the bank with being an accessory
to tax evasion after seven years
fighting hard at least people know what
those banks were doing ah it's a
progress but as long as the top managers
do not go to jail nothing will ever
change you know the banks pay huge fines
especially in the US and so what the
language of a bank is money this is it
Stephanie Gebo says although she may
seem like a perfectly normal woman
inside she's become a new person there's
no going back after you make the
decision to become a whistleblower
you